[Musique]
un nouvel essai d'automoto la polo
volkswagen est bien dans les
encombrements cette peinture est très
maniable la direction est précise
peut-être un petit peu démultiplier la
visibilité très bonne on domine vraiment
le capot où exactement l'on passe comme
la voiture est très courte au point de
vue parking on trouve relativement
facilement des places quand y en a de
gros avantages de cette nature aussi la
boîte se manie très bien donc pas de
fatigue la [ __ ] d'embrayage et douce
le piedoux c'est une voiture de vivre
[Musique]
notre essayeur est un expert c'est le
rallyman jean vinatier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien le premier contact avec cette
voiture c'est une surprise d'avoir une
ceinture à enrouleur de série maintenant
la position de conduite est excellente
le volant est très incliné on peut avoir
les bras
relativement tendue a légèrement plié
qui est la position idéale et on trouve
des sièges et galbées qui permettent ici
de bien maintenir les reins et de se
tenir dans les virages vraiment très
bien au point de vue position de
conduite
on nous sommes sur une autoroute de la
sortie de paris est
est à peu près 130 kilomètres/heure
potter est un fait que c'est un petit
peu difficile à y arriver parce que
c'est une petite cinq chevaux on y
arrive
de même et tout va bien le niveau sonore
comme vous pouvez le constater est
extrêmement faible
c'est la première chose qui m'a frappé
en prenant cette volkswagen polo c'est
de voir une voiture
disons mode est au point de vue prix de
revient et encombrement de ce véhicule
avoir un niveau sonore cyborg
c'est une voiture très compact et très
agréable à conduire
elle est très logeable on tient
facilement à 4 mais je pense que cette
voiture est tout de même
destiné à une utilisation urbaine et non
routières
[Applaudissements]
ça fera mieux en définitive que je ne
pensais 132 km heure en pointe 7 litre
d'essence ordinaire au sens la polo sera
commercialisé à partir du mois de
juillet son prix définitif ne nous a pas
été communiqué
[Musique]